quand est ce que je serai remboursé
puis je faire une cure thermale cette
année je pars en vacances à l'étranger
est ce que ma mutuelle voyage avec moi
vous avez toujours plein de question
pour nous et c'est tant mieux car nous
sommes là pour y répondre
téléphonez nous ou demander à être
rappelé tout est clair et précis sur
notre site
une mutuelle qui vit avec vous votre
quotidien
c'est ça une mutuelle qui va bien venez
clic et on en parle
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
check-up votre magazine santé et
bien-être
au programme de ce numéro nous avons
passé une soirée en compagnie d'une
équipe de la croix rouge durant une
marode reportage en immersion avec ses
bénévoles
la ville de voisins-le-bretonneux a mis
en place une mutuelle de villages une
mutuelle réservé aux travailleurs et aux
habitants nous nous sommes également
rendus à trappes pour assister à une des
rencontres santé organisée par la ville
une rencontre sur la santé de l'homme et
pour continuer menace autour du centre
géré handicap la structure pourrait
fermer à cause de son déficit
nous vous expliquerons pourquoi mais
pour commencer depuis 150 ans des hommes
et des femmes s'engagent à la croix
rouge en offrant leur temps et leur
énergie pour venir en aide aux
nécessiteux sur saint quentin en
yvelines des bénévoles s'active et se
relaient chaque semaine pour porter
assistance aux populations en difficulté
dans le secteur sephora namani et
camille lambert ont accompagné certains
d'entre eux qui participent au maroc
s'est tournée nocturne auprès des sans
domicile fixe couvertures vêtements qui
d'hygiène élémentaires sont rassemblés
il est 19h30
michel il son équipe bénévole de la
croix rouge de saint quentin en yvelines
près par leurs maraudes
objectif apporter une aide d'urgence à
des gens qui en ont fait la demande dans
la journée ce soit des aides locales en
aide alimentaire vestimentaire d'autres
choses psychologique des fois on vient
parler simplement
et puis éventuellement si l'on n'en font
ils nous en font la demande on peut les
emmener dans un hébergement sur les
héllènes je crois qu'il ya 80 places
d'hébergement qu'ils sont gérées par la
croix rouge et donc on les transporte
jusqu'aux hébergement si l'on fait la
demande
20 heures la voiture est chargé il est
temps de partir je crois qu'on a rien
oublié
l'essentiel ce qui va faire froid il
risque de faire froid
oui donc nous sommes prêts à partir un
appel avant de partir à la régulation
pour connaître la première destination
direction nantes la jolie pour apporter
des soins de première nécessité cet
homme vit dans la rue depuis plus de 25
ans
il ya de quoi
pas à manger ça peut nous permet de
parler on peut leur demander des soins
comme si donc comment y avait décollé ou
les du ciom peyo puisqu'il faut plutôt
livre conte preste souffrent d'une
importante infection à l'oeil gauche des
soins lui sont régulièrement prodigués
la croix rouge a aussi la possibilité de
le transporter aux urgences au coeur
packard stable à des gens qui sont
encore plus précaire tous les handicapés
qui sont des situations de précarité
difficile à surmonter dans les premiers
temps pour les bénévoles
une psychologue leur permet d'échanger
sur leurs expériences
on s'aperçoit qu'effectivement quand les
gens débute dans le dans ce genre
d'activités
il ya ressentent les gens prennent sur
eux puis quelques mois après ça ressort
on parle des situations étaient choqués
les premières fois oui et puis après va
comme l'expliqué michel une fois qu'on a
gardé qu'on a compris que c'est une
mission et que on les aide à notre
manière on arrive à garder
l'essor de distance qui vont bien pour
pas être trop
on va dire impactés ça reste quelque
chose de difficile toujours un conte la
jolie et ont fait un transport vers
satory l'homme n'a pas souhaité être
filmé il sera bien déposer au centre
d'hébergement d'urgence de satory qui
accueille 38 places il est maintenant
23h30 la maraude s'arrêtent les
différents équipements sont vos
conditionné pour la prochaine fois à
minuit tout est en ordre
les bénévoles rentrer chez eux michel
bernard ferme le centre croix rouge de
guyancourt avec l'espoir d'avoir été
utile ce soir est une motivation
toujours aussi forte pour recommencer le
mois prochain
c'est la nouveauté de ce début d'année à
voisins le bretonneux
la ville vient de mettre en place une
mutuelle de village exclusivement
réservé aux habitants et aux personnes
travaillant dans la commune
objectif annoncé faciliter l'accès aux
soins avec des tarifs préférentiels
les détails avec michael et demi d'euros
et florent lamothe une mutuelle de
village pour faciliter l'accès aux soins
à voisins le bretonneux c'est la mesure
phare annoncée par la maire de la
commune avec son art aux eti pendant ses
voeux vendredi dernier objectif de ce
dispositif permet trop 8,6 noyau
personnes travaillant à voisin d'être
couverts à des tarifs préférentiels
négocié par la ville c'est souvent là la
première économique les gens font sur
leurs dépenses
il supprime la mutuelle
on sait bien que les problèmes de santé
qu'on peut avoir avoir une mutuelle
c'est vraiment capital
donc on s'est dit que on se regroupant
comme l'ont fait d'autres villes eh bien
on pourrais je dirais être plus forts et
y avoir des bons tarifs pour développer
ce projet un questionnaire a été lancée
dans la ville pour identifier les
besoins des habitants
les frais d'hospitalisation d'optique et
soins dentaires ont été plébiscités par
les vies si noir ce qui nous intéresse
mon épouse et moi c'est le prix je
trouve que l'initiative de la mairie est
une bonne chose
cette mutuelle de couverture santé ses
skis et prendront des cours
croyez vous important est de plus en
plus important jeu qu'à des mets donc je
crois que c'est quelque chose qui
préoccupe beaucoup les retraités ce qui
est mon cas
à l'issue d'un appel d'offres la
mutuelle prévoyance des salariés mps a
été retenu par la municipalité
la cotisation mensuelle individuel
démarre à 58 euros 50 par mois pour les
50 ans et plus le tarif est à 25 euros
40 pour les moins de 30 ans disons que
la comparaison qui a été fait par
voisins-le-bretonneux
ils ont trouvé nos cotisations adapté
par rapport aux prestations
contrairement aux uns des autres à
d'autres propositions qui leur étaient
faites pour plus d'informations la
mutuelle proposés permanence le prochain
rendez vous est fixé le 27 janvier
prochain à la maison des associations
tous les mois attrape des rencontres
avec un médecin sont organisés pour
discuter santé mardi 12 janvier au
centre socioculturel annette moreau à
mieux un après midi d'échangés autour de
la santé de l'homme et participants ont
pu approfondir leurs connaissances sur
l'organe génital masculin et son
fonctionnement
reportage c'est une assistance
exclusivement composée de femmes qui
écoutent attentivement le docteur
jacques segal parler de prostate
d'érection ou d'andropause l'objectif de
cette rencontre autour de la santé de
l'homme expliqué au public l'organe
génital masculin et son fonctionnement
est long plus d'informations sur
l'anatomie de la femme que sur
l'anatomie de l'homme et elles savent
très peu de choses sur la sexualité de
l'homme et sur les mécanismes qui
permettent les rapports sexuels pourtant
ouverte à tous ces rencontres
accueillent généralement un public
féminin venu chercher des informations
utiles qui leur permettront de mieux
comprendre leur conjoint ou leur enfant
pour beaucoup de deux femmes quelles que
soient les cultures c'est difficile de
voir des images du sexe de l'homme
d'entendre parler de comment ça
fonctionne etc mais aussi au fait ça de
façon détendue et respectueuse et bien a
pas de réseau non plus de véhiculer des
tabous parce que ce sont des tables le
but du docteur segal faire tomber ses
tabous par la parole en expliquant même
certaines pathologies
au début des questions sont timides mais
toujours pertinente
un premier pas difficile mais
aujourd'hui c'est vénus qui l'a fait
vermaas
le centre géré handicap est en danger le
pôle gérontologique implantée depuis
2009 dans le domaine du mes rentes et
affiche un déficit de 40 mille euros une
dette due à des retards de loyers
conséquence la structure pourrait fermer
dans les prochains mois un reportage de
mickaël millero et simon liel
le pôle gérondi cap pourrait fermer ses
portes courant 2016 la structure
gérontologique située à magny les
hameaux fait face à des difficultés
financières le centre spécialisé dans
l'aide aux personnes en perte
d'autonomie affiche un déficit de 40
mille euros la raison le loyer demandé
par saint quentin en yvelines le
propriétaire des lieux seraient trop
élevés ce loyer donc correspond quelque
sorte un loyer donc pour une structure
marchande des gens qui effectivement
font un travail qui sent qu'elle ils
gagnent beaucoup d'argent
ici nous sommes dans une structure
sociale effectivement donc on ne gagne
pas d'argent
aujourd'hui la situation est compliquée
d'autant que certains partenaires se
retire donc là l'effort qui va être
porté par l'agglomération
da c'est tout simplement de dire go on
va essayer de trouver un nouveau loyer
pour que tous ceux qui plie qui
souhaitent rester dans le giron des caps
puisse le faire mais aux conditions que
nous avons fixés si aucun accord n'est
trouvé le centre pourrait fermer ses
portes au mois de juin
sept postes seront alors supprimer une
vingtaine de patients devront trouver
une nouvelle structure d'accueil
c'est inhumain je veux dire franchement
si inhumain alors qu'on ne sacrifie qui
est magique qui il correspond dans
quelque chose qui est est donc vécue et
qui reconnut reconnu je me battrai pour
que ça ne ferme pas une réunion pourrait
être programmé dans les prochaines
semaines entre les membres de gérer
handicapés les responsables de
l'agglomération saint-quentinoise
et pour terminer voici l'agenda de dates
à retenir tout d'abord l'ufr des
sciences et de la santé accueille une
après-midi des changes destiné aux
professionnels de la santé souhaitant
s'installer dans les yvelines où le val
d'oise pour y participer rendez vous à
lui vs que le jeudi 28 janvier à 14
heures et puis le mercredi 3 février la
maison de quartier auguste renoir de
guyancourt organise une soirée débat
entre parents et professionnels pour
comprendre et accompagner les enfants
souffrant de troubles dys n'hésitez pas
à vous inscrire en téléphonant voilà
check up c'est maintenant terminé quant
à moi je vous donne rendez-vous dans
deux semaines pour un prochain numéro
et d'ici là prenez soin de vous